kicsit beszélgessünk magáról a
hadseregről ugyanis ez
egy
érdekes felállás hogy a nőket is
bevonják a hadseregbe tehát h kötelező
hadsereg van kötelező sorozás van a nők
számára is erről egy kicsit tudnál
mesélni hogy ez hogyan működik te
kellett-e
ezen a sorozáson részt vegyél
besoroztak-e téged is nem ne nekem nincs
ilyen kötelezettségem mert én én úgymond
már öreg vagyok tehát hogy én 35 éves
voltam
amikor kijöttem és ez a katonaság az 18
évtől kezdődik és a fiúknak nagyjából
három év és a a nőknek két év igazából
izraelben
egyetem előtt úgymond katonák lesznek az
emberek h ami ami én azt látom hogy
érettebb embereket termel ki a
társadalomnak tehát hogy a mi esetünkben
ilyen ilyen a a mi rendszerünk ilyen
okos tónikad neve hogy kimegyünk a
liíceumból és akkor megyünk egyetemre és
ülünk a könyvtárba és tanulunk szesszió
tehát ilyen ilyen okostónik leszünk de
nem nem leszünk érettek és itt itt előbb
lesznek az emberek érettek és utána
utána jobban megtöltik a fejüket tudásra
azt látom